so let's say someone has made a bold
move to come from wherever to LA in New
York one of these major cities but then
they've been here several years and now
they're in a new kind of rut new kind of
comfort zone yeah I'm going out I'm
submitting fill in the blank of whatever
it is they're submitting but it's habit
driven and it's not really going
anywhere and they feel stagnant but
everyone else hey they're here in this
big city or wherever and they're
supposedly working there supposedly
getting stuff out there how do you shake
that up and I know I'm being a little
bit vague but let's just say they're
here it's not very okay if you want to
learn to play tennis find yourself a pro
that's the game that's how you improve
the problem most creatives have when you
know they they they come to LA they come
to New York they go wherever they are
and they what do they do
most of them learn bad habits why
because they're learning and mimicking
like people around them I have an actor
I'm following what other actors are
doing I'm asking them I'm learning from
them and yet they're not at the top of
the totem same with writers same with
producer same with it doesn't matter
human beings writers as one example I
get query letters every day line query
letters
dear so-and-so it could be my name it
could be creative executive it could be
my name is spelled it could be anything
dear so-and-so logline short description
you know can I send you a script I'll
sign a release sign John that's what I
get repeatedly all day long in my inbox
there is not one lick of research there
is not one lick of anything personal
like why is this the writer the only
writer who could have written this story
why was it so compelling that they chose
this out of all the stories in one's
imagination why did they choose to send
it to me now I don't want to receive the
agony and ecstasy as a letter but
something I'd drop a kernel something
that stands out and makes them makes me
think makes me react makes me wonder
about this but they don't I can promise
you not even 1% do what I'm describing
so this is what writers learn from other
writers it could be actors learning from
other actress etc they learn the
habitual tried-and-true day-to-day
protocol which is usually very
unsuccessful the the ROI the return on
investment in sending blind query
letters has gotta be horribly
frustrating if you're a business you'd
be bankrupt so why do it you do it
because this is what other people are
doing you need to associate with with
more successful people and you need to
think about it differently if you were a
fashion designer and you took that
approach you focus on your craft focus
on your craft focus on your craft and
send out letters saying here's my
designs aren't I great you'd never have
a brand you have to think in terms of
business you have to think in terms of
what what more could I do that others
aren't doing as opposed to what they are
doing
how do I stand out
separating yourself out from the herd is
definitely the name of the game and
anyone who's invested all that blood
blood sweat and tears that sort of soul
equity investing all that time writing a
hundred and twenty or ten pages of
whatever of story and rewriting it till
it's just so but they want to share
their wares with the world now they're
so proud of this they should they should
invest a like amount of time in figuring
out how to market and how to be a
business person and how to reach out to
people how to do things differently than
all their peers like that's a great
measurement am i doing what everyone
else is doing or am I being somehow
putting myself out into the world and
speaking of myself to the right people
in ways that matter you mentioned
fashion had me thinking of Diane von
Furstenberg and her wrap dress and how
it was this dress that no one had really
ever seen it and it fit every body type
it made every body type look good so I
just don't know you're talking about
fashion side kind of thinking about that
how many times do we see artists leave
jobs Johnny Cash you know I mean Lady
Gaga you know I mean it's there's a
million ways to stand out
you